what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
if you are here you are most likely very
excited for the upcoming mcu's Fantastic
Four now lately we've talked a lot about
the cast of The Fantastic Four but
mainly just about our Fantastic Four
members Reed Richards aka Mr Fantastic
Sue storm AKA The Invisible Woman Johnny
Storm AKA The Human Torch and Ben Grimm
aka the thing we've done many videos
about the cast of The Fantastic Four
already you can check those out but
today we're going to be specifically
talking about the villain of the
Fantastic Four which we believe to be
Galactus and a couple of his Heralds
that'll be coming along with him now
when we think about the Fantastic Four
the Silver Surfer Galactus Dr Doom these
are just some of the villains that come
to mind as the most iconic and Galactus
is definitely one of the most iconic not
only Marvel villains but specifically
Fantastic Four villains and a look looks
like he could be played in the MCU by
Antonio Banderas now we have briefly
talked about this rumor in the past but
now it seems like there's a lot of
credit to it and now it seems like
Antonio Banderas himself might have
actually teased this Antonio Banderas
himself has recently released a video
that shows him getting a cast or a mold
made of his face the quote is getting an
exact copy of his face built or a movie
and the video is posted as well that you
can see here now this is really
interesting because this is happening
right when the rumor appeared of him
possibly playing Galactus for the
Fantastic Four MCU movie and what is
kind of the biggest deal of Galactus his
space his face and the iconic helmet
mostly because in the comics his head is
as big or bigger than planets he's the
Devourer of Worlds and he has the size
to actually do it now whether or not
they're going to use Antonio Banderas
body or just his face it doesn't really
matter because it's going to be a huge
improvement from the last Galactus that
we saw in the Rise of the Silver Surfer
so pretty much as long as Antonio
Banderas isn't a huge Cloud he's gonna
be all right now right away go ahead and
let us know what you think in the
comments if you think Antonio Banderas
is a good choice for Galactus I
personally do think that he has a really
great voice for the character which is
one of the biggest parts of Galactus
obviously they can CJ his face in any
way to make him look like Galactus Plus
at the helmet so as far as the look of
Galactus goes yes his face could do a
great job as Galactus but the voice is a
really big part and this is a really big
role because Galactus has had his hands
in many different story events
throughout Marvel Comics sometimes as
the villain sometimes fighting with the
heroes and sometimes just kind of
neutral and the thing is Galactus isn't
necessarily a villain per se obviously
he's a big bad villain a big bad threat
to you if the planet that he wants to
devour is yours but he is actually sort
of just a necessity to the universe that
is what eternity the embodiment of the
universe itself says in the comics that
Galactus is necessary and does sort of
balance the universe him and Thanos
could have been best friends in fact I
wouldn't be surprised if we learned that
Thanos at one point in time sought
Galactus to help him sort of balance the
universe until Thanos discovered the
Infinity Stones so this is a role that
Antonio Banderas or whoever else might
end up taking this role is going to
probably have for a pretty decent time
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe not as
a big bad but as a big Cosmic character
that could have multiple parts to play
in multiple different story lines this
has actually been a pretty decent debate
within the Marvel fandom so far with all
the rumors coming of Galactus people are
talking about him possibly being a big
bad or him not being big enough to be a
big bad and the issue with him being a
big bad is that his motivation is simply
only to survive he literally requires
sustenance to maintain his existence
that is why he devours worlds to survive
he doesn't really have any big conqueror
plans his goal is not to rule the entire
universe or rule a few planets he simply
needs sustenance to survive so he has
his Heralds go seek out planets that are
right for him to consume they find
planets for him and he goes and he most
of the time devours them until he comes
to Earth of course in the comics and the
Fantastic Four drive him away so the
argument of him not being a big bat is
he doesn't really have any big bad
intentions again they're viewed as big
bad intentions if the world he's about
to consume is your world and you're
about to die but he isn't exactly like
Thanos seeking out to balance the
universe eternity says that this is what
he does but that's not his intentions
his intentions aren't even necessarily
evil to himself he's not exactly an evil
being and like I said he has even fought
with Heroes on occasion and this is why
I kind of actually like Antonio Banderas
for this role because I really like
Antonio Banderas as a good guy but I
really also like him as some mysterious
parts and some bad guy Parts as well all
of which I think Galactus has there are
surprisingly a lot of different aspects
to Galactus that can be had in the MCU
he could start off as a villain be
pushed away from Earth and of course
return to Earth to try to devour it but
he could also be a key character to play
in some of the cosmic stories of the MCU
especially if we really dive into the
celestials trying to destroy Earth as
well in fact that would be a pretty cool
storyline the celestials coming into
conflict with Galactus that is something
that I truly hope we do see in the MCU
at some point in time now galactus's
Heralds are of course a huge part of the
story with the Fantastic Four as well
the Silver Surfer is the most known
Herald however we have heard some
reports that the Silver Surfer might not
be the herald or one of the Heralds to
show up in the Fantastic Four film we
have been hearing reports of course for
a while that the Silver Surfer is
supposed to get a special presentation
coming from Disney plus Marvel Studios
has not confirmed this yet and we are
not sure when exactly this is going to
be released either before the Fantastic
Four movie or after but recent rumors
have suggested that he is not going to
be one of the Heralds that show up in
the Fantastic Four film but the Silver
Surfer not being the herald of Galactus
in the Fantastic Four movie could open
up the door for a really cool storyline
although the full history of every
single Herald that Galactus has had is
not fully known we do know of many
different Heroes that he's had like the
Fallen one and Terex the only problem
with this is that of course Galactus
gives his Heralds the power Cosmic a
fraction of the power Cosmic that is
Galactus holds the full power but
there's a problem with some of these
Heralds they revolt against Galactus and
try to defeat him they're hostile and
can't be controlled by Galactus so
therefore he either defeats them or
imprisons them so there could be some
conflict between galactus's Heralds and
himself in the Fantastic Four film
especially if we're going for kind of an
origin of Galactus this could lead us to
Galactus wanting a more tame a more
noble and loyal Herald which could lead
us to noren rad aka the Silver Surfer
after the Fantastic Four movie this
could also give the Fantastic Four a
little bit more to deal with a couple of
Heralds plus Galactus all in all making
for a pretty good story if this is what
we have to expect for the Fantastic Four
in the MCU also I gotta say that the
current lineup that we have for the
Fantastic Four atom driver Margot Robbie
Paul muskel and David Diggs I think they
would mesh really well going up against
Antonio Banderas as Galactus I think
this would be a good call but let us
know what you think about this in the
comments down below do you like this
idea and do you think Antonio Banderas
would make a good Galactus let us know
your thoughts don't forget to like the
video and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
gets to pick one item and we pick a
winner at the end of each month also
don't forget to follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf